one deals with the Saints it's a given
at this point Drew Brees is gonna be out
yeah for at least a little bit right
yeah thumb ligament
maybe surgery whatever the case may be
he's not gonna be able to play for a
while yes so what do you do a
quarterback yeah a few New Orleans
Saints you have Teddy Bridgewater you
have Taysom Hill yeah yeah that's a
really good question
I mean Taysom Hill first off as you know
it was phenomenal in the preseason
I mean phenomenal not just like athletic
like oh wow he's a freaky athlete and he
can make plays his throwing and
quarterback play went up another level
from what we saw as compared to last
year like he understands how to move in
the pocket and throw a touch and you
know change arm angles and read offenses
like all that's improved to where he
certainly closed the gap between Teddy
Bridgewater
and I would say maybe past him now the
big question is I'm like first off I was
shocked we didn't see him a little in
the game yet they're an interesting
theory and my theory is a little bit
what was the first thing is you know I
think Sean Payton if he did have a taste
some he'll package when oh I might have
to make this guy my starting quarterback
in a week or two and I don't want to do
the Taysom Hill package now and have him
run between the tackles and get killed
by Aaron Donald or whatever it may be
now the other theory could also be gosh
I'm down to two quarterbacks and he's my
backup and I need to keep him healthy
just in case something happened to Teddy
Bridgewater too so it could be either
way but I would think with the way the
preseason unfolded and his averages
Teddy Bridgewater looked in preseason
and yesterday that Taysom Hill the
starter has got to be in Sean Payton's
mind a little bit at a minimum you get
both guys ready and you use both guys
because that puts more pressure on the
defense at a minimum yeah I'll tell you
some help right you get him out there
right you do it with Drew Brees yeah
you're gonna get him out there with
Teddy Bridgewater if Teddy Bridgewater's
the starter here's what Sean Payton said
about Taysom Hill last month in
comparing him to Steve Young yurga
butter laissez-faire laissez-faire let
Sean Payton said if you look back at
Steve's career people don't remember the
time before he came to the NFL you have
a very athletic player that I think
advanced when he got to San Francisco
he always had great ability with his
legs so you're trying to create visions
for players and that's no
different than how you evaluate how we
see teddy bridgewater progressing in
what we think it can be that's the
business were in the bottom line is
restrained effort by Sean Payton to say
I got a lump of clay here they could be
pretty damn good if I shape it the right
way and Payton is a master of studying
everything that happens in the NFL hmm
cherry-picking ideas that he thinks will
work with his personnel yeah and putting
his players you talked about this with
the 49ers where guys are wide open
that's great coaching yeah Sean Payton
is great at that play selection play
design right using a place at the right
time setting up a defense and springing
guys wide open so I could hit the guy
yeah so you know it could be Bridgewater
he could be Hill right but if you have
that that caught a minimum a combination
yeah maybe taste some Hills the guy at a
minimum you got to get him on the field
and I like your theory that they kept
him off the field yesterday because he
may be the starter and they didn't want
to lose two guys in the same day against
the ranch I think it just you know
trying to put myself in his shoes and
again we don't know we're speculating
but I would think that's the logic there
and really honestly again I'm not trying
to be like negative towards Teddy
Bridgewater but I think the ceilings
higher would taste some Hill and what he
can do with that offense and what I've
seen to this point and I know Teddy
Bridgewater's a fine player but I think
he's really a backup he's a career
backup in my eyes where I look at Taysom
Hill like you're saying a lump of clay
where I go there's a chance he could be
Steve Young there is a chance I mean
there's no doubt about it he's proven
that I've seen enough already to go oh
in two years he's made giant leaps and
bounds and quarterback play and the way
he throws and all of those things to
make me think that I something special
might happen here and I think Sean
Payton might see that same type of
vision and he is such an amazing athlete
two years ago when he was playing
special teams that guy is so fast guys
look bad right when they watched the
film it's like other guys are in slow
motion no yeah that's just how fast
Taysom Hill right yeah no he is I mean
he hustles he's I mean rocked up I mean
some of the collisions you see him make
sometimes I'm just like oh my gosh he
can take he can take down linebackers
like a running back and I you know if he
does start at quarterback he's got
that kind of stuff but yeah I'll be
interested to see where this whole
quarterback situation goes for the same
and here's the other thing too now that
Sean Payton has a new contract Jay
Glazer reported that on Sunday five
years beyond this year six years total
of a commitment he will be there after
Drew Brees yeah so the future is coming
the future may be right now so why not
fully evaluate the guys you have and
Taysom Hill as the guy who's got the
higher seal I think we can agree on that
yes Taysom Hill has a much higher
ceiling than Teddy bridge yes definitely
so why not get him ready and get him on
yeah III and Roode for that I not love
Teddy Bridgewater right it's a shame
what happened three years ago derailed
his career we never got a chance to see
how good he could be in Minnesota right
but that's where he is right now and I
think Taysom Hill does a better we see
that glimmer that there could be some
greatness there
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports